there has long been speculation of
tunnels shafts and chambers within the
Great Sphinx and underneath it including
the possibility of a Hall of Records in
this video I'm gonna share with you
several key pieces of evidence that
prove that not only do these tunnels
shafts and chambers exist but there is
an active attempt on behalf of the
Egyptian authorities to prevent the
citizens of the world from knowing about
it
let me start off by addressing the
conspiracy that there is some sort of
shaft door at the top of the Sphinx's
head at least that's what many people
have referred to it as various articles
I've looked at videos online about this
and you see people leaving comments
saying that no this is CGI there's no
door at the top that's non-existent it's
just a color fluctuation and it means
nothing so I decided to go looking into
this for myself and I looked through
Google Images and realize that there are
so few aerial photos of the Sphinx
apparently the Egyptian authorities do
not allow people to fly over it so I
went to Google Maps and that was useless
because as you can see in the largest
photo here that is as far as you can
zoom in so I cropped the photograph or I
took a screenshot cropped it and I mean
yeah you can kind of see a white blemish
there but I mean what does this do for
me so I went over to the Google Earth
app and look at that what that's just
useless it's animated I mean what am I
supposed to do with this and it didn't
always used to be this way so I decided
to go back to Google Images and do a ton
of different searches I got really
creative and I did find a photo from
1925 and as you can see here I mean
there's a guy standing in it but is this
what a four or five foot deep cavity is
it a shaft does it go anywhere
it really doesn't show us much but then
I hit the jackpot I don't think anyone
watching this has seen these photos so
there's a photographer who is doing a
story with the New York Times back in
May of 1990 and as you can see in this
photo here yes that is dr. Zahi Hawass
himself in the middle there but pay
close attention to the scaffolding over
at the top of the Sphinx's head because
in this next photo well just take a look
for it and see for yourself look at that
what is that now I don't know what else
there is the photographer doesn't point
down there this is all you can see
there's a hatch but does it go anywhere
is
any possibility that it's related to the
imaging the ground-penetrating radar
that has discovered some sort of
cavities within the Sphinx could it lead
to the so-called chamber at the paw of
the Sphinx as I'll be discussing here
shortly
there's obviously not enough information
here to make any type of conclusion but
clearly no this is not CGI and I find it
really interesting that the Egyptian
authorities have done so much to prevent
anyone from knowing about this in the
first place now there has been other
speculation and this brings me to my
second example that there is some sort
of shaft door at the top and the Sphinx
is back towards the rear and in fact
Zahi Hawass actually took people up
there with a camera in 2009 and yeah
this this shaft door exists he opens it
up on video and I'll include a link for
the video in the description here it's
three and a half minutes long you
definitely need to watch it but he opens
up the door he points down and clearly
you can see that at the bottom I mean it
goes someplace you can tell from the
shadows which direction does it go I
have no idea
he himself say says that it leads
nowhere and you go down there and
there's nothing to be seen he says that
people probably dug it out at some point
looking for treasures why not just put a
camera attached a rope to a camera and
lower it down let us see you can tell
that it goes in some direction so which
direction does it go it's fine if
there's nothing down there but at least
show us a photograph show us an image of
some kind why is it such a secret
and don't forget Zahi Hawass had denied
for decades that there was ever tunnels
underneath the sphinx or in the sphinx
itself and he had actually changed his
story multiple times as I'll discuss
later in this video but it raises
questions could this lead to the
cavities within the Sphinx or the
detected cavity at below it I mean guys
ground-penetrating radar has shown that
there's something there now let me go on
to the next example which is this
infamous shaft tunnel doorway at the
base of the Sphinx at the rear to the
left of the tail so look at these photos
here anyone that's visited the site you
can't see what's down there it goes to
the left it's too dark but dr. Zahi
Hawass himself in the same video as him
going to the Sphinx is back and showing
you that tunnel he actually goes down
into this chamber and that through this
shaft and he takes a camera guy with
them and Zahi himself in this video
states that it doesn't go anywhere that
he's excavated it and there's nothing to
be seen but the cameraman doesn't even
point the camera in the opposite
direction just I mean clearly it goes
somewhere right how difficult would it
be to have the cameraman turnaround
point a flashlight and let us see what's
in there which direction does it go okay
you say there's nothing in there but at
least let us see the nothing why is
there not one single photo or video
available to the public that shows
anything beyond this point and most
people don't even know that this exists
in itself what's interesting about this
is that in the 1970s a stone block came
loose so they began an excavation where
mark Lehner was part of it a very close
associate of Zahi Hawass for decades
they spent three weeks excavating this
tunnel shaft that Zahi Hawass says goes
nowhere and there's nothing in it I mean
I know that excavations take some time
but three weeks if it went nowhere and
there was nothing in it and they decided
to go ahead and shroud it in the process
where nobody could see what they were
doing okay and not to mention stories go
back centuries that there is a tunnel
system that connects the Great Sphinx
and the Hall of Records to the pyramids
could this lead to that now the next
example I want to discuss involves what
ground-penetrating radar has discovered
as a cavity of some kind a chamber
underneath the pod the Sphinx and this
is something that's been discussed by
John Anthony West Robert Schoch but Zahi
Hawass took a team they did some
drilling and they concluded that well
they found absolutely nothing but
there's nothing underneath it and
there's nothing to be seen here so just
to clarify as he's saying that
ground-penetrating radar was wrong like
what you know in why aren't you letting
anyone else see this for themselves why
did you cap it off and prevent any other
archaeologists from checking it out such
as John Anthony West and Robert Schoch
but then I saw something really
interesting while watching one of Brian
foresters videos about this topic
he points out an incredibly interesting
fact which is that the Sphinx itself is
carved out of limestone bedrock and all
around the Sphinx itself is limestone
bedrock to the left of it to the right
of it and in between the pause except
for one area in front of the pause that
has these stone tiles and you can see
here that they have been starting to
replace them they're very old and
they've been doing maintenance and
restorations to it but why would you
have the stone
miles in front of the Sphinx the only
place around that has these by the way
and it just so happens to be located
where ground-penetrating radar has
identified a cavity of a chamber of some
kind and as you look at these other
photos they have since covered up the
entire site at least in front of it with
these stone tiles with these boardwalks
could these tiles be indicative of some
sort of roofing system for the chamber
below you know I want to point something
else that's really interesting so if you
go to Wikipedia which of course I do not
endorse for so many reasons but if you
go and look up the Great Sphinx and
Wikipedia do a control-f search for the
words shaft chamber tunnel underground
under sinks anything under the Sphinx
Hall of Records and not one single of
these words pops up not one of them now
that's really interesting but if you
look up the Hall of Records which has
its own Wikipedia page you'll find a
link to the Great Sphinx yeah and of
course you'll find a link to pseudo
archaeology as well now if you think
that Wikipedia is unreliable because of
the fact that anyone can edit it well
that's actually no longer the case and
it hasn't been for several years now
Wikipedia has been bought and paid for
and cheryl atkinson who i highly
recommend you check out her TED talk
about this subject outlines it in detail
and if you don't believe me on this try
and do the edit yourself and see what
happens now then he transitions to
something incredibly interesting dr.
Zahi Hawass himself went on TV he stated
that he found a shaft 29 meters down 95
feet approximately that's located
directly between or exactly between the
Sphinx in the second pyramid itself chef
Ron also known as Khafre
he stated that there's a tomb down there
and most likely to be the god Osiris
himself the god of the underworld the
god of the afterlife in fact he's famous
for seeing this judgment scene as you
see here but you can find him everywhere
else these depictions are in the Valley
of the Kings and all over the place and
of course it's interesting that he
always has green skin it makes you
wonder what that's about so I came
across a video now this is from Fox and
this was filmed I believe in 1999 it
could have been 96 but they take a crew
down there they take this lady and they
actually go to the site and here I'm
showing you screenshots from this video
and I highly recommend you check out
this video the link is in the
scription it's 13 minutes long and it is
fascinating but then to get through this
so as you can see here it has multiple
layers or levels and they stagger off
and the deepest is 95 feet down so they
go down this chamber this shaft carved
through solid limestone bedrock in the
first or I should say the middle level
there is a set of tombs and there's a
cefco focus in there as well even some
bone fragments as well but the place has
apparently been looted or something so
as they keep going and as you can see
here they go from the imbibed by the way
this is 55 feet or 65 feet deep it was
hard to tell what she said in the video
because of audio issues but as they go
to the next set of shafts that goes from
that 50 60 foot mark down to the
approximately 100 feet down look how
impressive this thing is so it dives
down to the depths of the earth
underneath the Giza Plateau and in it
there is this incredible burial site for
massive pillars with hieroglyphs and
petroglyphs surrounded by a water moat
and by the way this site was completely
submerged in water when they found it
they had to pump it out it took a while
and as he shows her this massive
sarcophagus it's still about a foot down
underwater he thinks that it's probably
a Cyrus but they weren't sure yet as
they were still conducting the ago
vation and this sarcophagus itself is
nine feet long the lid and the box
individually are approximately 11 to 12
tons according to sahi Hawass and when
the lady asks him how did they bring
this massive thing down here he gives a
theory he'd said he doesn't know but his
theory is that they would have probably
done a dug a second shaft so first they
dig the first shaft they fill it with
sand and then they dig a second shaft
right next to it and start moving sand
away and it slowly lowers itself down by
itself that makes sense except for the
fact that there's no evidence for this
this shaft if this is indeed the case
you'd have to be able to find it within
the perimeter of the chamber itself or
immediately with outside the perimeter
but there's some issues with this theory
besides the fact that archaeologists
never found it which I mean come on that
should be easy to find but again each
level it staggers between the shafts so
how many shafts would the secondary
shafts would they have to have dug and
again through limestone bedrock
that's not an easy task and look at the
precision of this but here's where it
gets even more interesting so Zahi
Hawass takes her to as you can see
there's these two tunnels the go extend
outwards from this tomb this burial site
itself one of which he claims has never
been excavated and he doesn't know
what's down there this is his own words
by the way you can watch this in the
video well first of all I don't believe
that you don't know what's down there
you didn't go take a peek like give me a
break but why not at least point the
camera down there with a flashlight for
just a second why does he have to block
it off like this which direction do
these tunnel shafts these these tunnels
go that's an incredibly important
question considering the fact that these
legends of a Hall of Records being
located under the Sphinx connects from
an underground tunnel from the Sphinx to
the pyramids themselves you know this is
the same guy that is back in Egypt
despite being fired from the minister of
Antiquities of Egypt for his corruption
despite the fact that a few years after
his firing he was implicated in a
massive theft of artifacts from a
pyramid this is what he's implicated in
he gets off the hook and now he's chosen
to be the guy leading the entire
excavation for the three mysteriously
discovered chambers within the Great
Pyramid itself as you may have seen in
the news and I've discussed this in
multiple other videos
he is the guy leading that that
discovery the same guy who changed his
story multiple times about the very
existence of chambers and tunnels in the
Sphinx itself has denied all that went
back and forth only to say well there is
some tunnels in some shafts but they
don't go anywhere there's nothing to see
we have to start connecting the dots on
this there are shafts there are tunnels
they don't show us any information I
mean isn't it pretty odd that there's
not a single photograph or video of
anything down underneath they show us
only a little bit and then just stop
there is that not suspicious or the fact
that they clearly control Wikipedia I
mean these anonymous moderators I mean
it's bought and paid for who do you
think's doing it whoever's doing it it's
not an accident that they completely
omit tunnels shafts chambers Hall of
Records all from the Wikipedia page of
the Great Sphinx and regardless of
whether you never even look at Wikipedia
it is still the world's most utilized
source of information it's not an
accident that shows up at the very top
of any
Google search so that's important
because this is deceiving
the citizens of the world they are
omitting information the cover-up is
real there's enough information to
conclude that there's something there we
know this so the question becomes does
that tunnel shaft that he showed us on
TV on Fox decades ago does that lead to
or from the Great Sphinx I'll close up
there
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe and leave me a comment let
me know what your thoughts are many more
videos to come with whole wide variety
of topics take care everybody